have any of the 42 illegal migrants on
the terrorist watch list or no-fly list
encountered on our southwest border been
released into the united states uh
ranking member jordan as i mentioned
before i will provide that data to you
with respect to the disposition of each
one i do not know the answer to your
question the secretary of homeland
security does not know the answer to the
status of 42 individuals who came to our
southern border illegally are on the
no-fly list and then and the no and the
terrorist watch list you do not do not
know of whether they have been released
or not into the country that's your
testimony ranking member jordan as i've
said before i will provide you the data
was that was a stunning exchange rather
telling jim jordan from ohio grilling
the homeland security secretary mayorkas
unable to give the basic information
during a house hearing fox news
contributor newt gingrich former speaker
of the house how you doing sir good
morning to you um
he either did not know or did not want
to answer
what would be your answer on that
well
look this administration has followed a
policy of secrecy and dishonesty on the
border they don't tell us where they're
sending what is now over a million
people
uh they fly them in late at night they
put them on trains and and
buses
and they literally refuse to tell people
where they're going
they have uh they're talking seriously
about dropping the public health
requirements which would mean 19 000
illegal immigrants a day is the current
estimate that's the city of atlanta
every month 12 atlantas a year in
illegal immigrants
majorcas is a combination of incompetent
and implementing the policies of joe
biden i mean biden has decided that he
wants an open border but he can't say it
that he's willing to accept anybody
whether they're diseased uh whether
they're carrying fentanyl uh whether
they have a criminal record
they're just not paying any attention
and the border patrol is now so drowning
in the sheer number of people they can't
compete with the cartels so what you've
seen is the cartel's gradually taking
control of the american southern border
the flood of fentanyl alone
and i was just in cobb county georgia
where six people had died in the
previous two weeks from fentanyl
and
this is madness i mean at a minimum
kevin mccarthy's right majorcas ought to
be impeached
but i think also the whole department
has to be overhauled and the idea that
they're not going to appoint some
left-wing zealot to become the
censorship czar for the united states
clearly unconstitutional clearly a
violation of the first amendment
and maybe a tribute to joe biden's
friends in the chinese communist party
or moscow
but certainly a very un-american and i
think this just tells you how out of
control they are
we have the statistics here about the
migrant encounters so far this year the
numbers are staggering and they are
out there for everyone to see but
earlier today as we were reporting on
this new quinnipiac poll
bill pointed out that if you look at the
breakdown of republicans and democrats
republicans think of immigration as our
number two concern after inflation in
the economy but for democrats it's way
down the list like number five or six or
so why do you think that is what do you
make of that
well i think historically republicans
have been much more committed to
american patriotism to the idea of the
nation i think on the left you have a
large block of people
who you know don't want to
stand for the national anthem they don't
want to
recognize the american flag as our
primary symbol they don't want to teach
american history accurately
and they frankly think it's just fine to
be drowned in people who don't
understand america haven't learned about
our country haven't assimilated
so i think there's a huge difference
there but interestingly among latinos
who used to be democrat the flood of
illegal immigrants is actually driving
them into the republican party and is i
think profoundly changing the politics
of the united states
tom mcclintock's a republican from
california he was doing a lot of the
questioning the last point on this
he told us that there will be no
progress on the border as long as the
current administration's in power
now he might be right or in a month from
now if you see 18 000 people a day
across the border
um that may have an impact the visual
that many will see what do you think
about that
well i think first of all the
republicans are going to win the house
and the senate i think one of the first
things they should do is send up a bill
requiring the completion of the wall
requiring control of the border it'll be
wildly popular with the country it'll
have 70 percent plus support
and
put it to biden and put it to the house
and senate democrats you want to vote
against controlling the border you want
to vote to continue to allow millions of
illegal immigrants to come in and
remember this is all going to keep
growing
the fact is when you have the governor
of california promising free health care
to anybody who's illegal who comes into
the u.s we're sending a signal there are
150 countries now that have sent illegal
immigrants to the united states in the
last two years 150 countries so this is
just going to get steadily worse and i
think it could be in january uh one of
the first really big fights between the
new republican congress and the
president and i think he's going to have
a hard time sustaining a veto
interesting thank you mr speaker nice to
see you have a great weekend thank you
very much